[Música]
hoy que vivimos en esta sociedad
científico tecnológica
rodeados de máquinas
ya está pensando nos a nosotros mismos
como máquinas que debemos funcionar bien
para rendir más
que confiamos más en lo digital que en
lo natural
les quiero hacer una invitación que
puede sonar un poco extraña
no renunciemos a la magia
menos aún a nuestra magia personal
y me voy a animar a sugerir que esta
puede ser una salida para la crisis
global contemporánea
y para eso quiero contar
una faceta oculta
de la historia de newton uno de los
hombres más influyentes uno de los
científicos más notables de la era
moderna cuando yo empecé a escribir mi
libro
me parecía imprescindible tratar de
demostrar y convencer a los lectores de
que estábamos viviendo una crisis global
y claro pasaron casi 15 años hasta que
termine de escribirlo y cuando estaba
por editarlo me di cuenta que esa
introducción donde describía tantos
indicadores de la crisis desde el cambio
climático las crisis económicas
financieras sociales los problemas de la
salud mundial etcétera etcétera que ya
no hacía falta que la crisis ya se había
demostrado por sí sola que todos sabemos
que estamos en crisis que la palabra
crisis resuena en todos los oídos que
hace acelerar todos nuestros corazones
por eso creo que hay
qué más queremos demostrar la la crisis
hoy hay que pensarla hay que reflexionar
y hacernos las preguntas adecuadas para
encontrar salidas
cómo fue que llegamos hasta aquí cómo
fue que en occidente durante la
modernidad ese futuro bienhechor que
pensaron e imaginaron los padres
fundadores de la ciencia moderna en
realidad nos terminó llevando a un
estado de crisis capital podríamos
dónde
sin ser catastrofista pero el tiempo
urge
hay que tomar decisiones
y vivimos en un mundo que muchos
calificamos como un mundo desencantado
porque ha perdido su encanto ha perdido
su gracia ha perdido y hemos perdido el
sentido de estar en este mundo
y por qué es que el alma humana ha
terminado siendo el territorio más
herido cómo es que el mayor consumo de
ansiolíticos para calmarnos
de somníferos para dormir necesitamos
estimulantes para empezar el día
antidepresivos para no caernos en un
pozo
y aquí es cuando quiero traer la
historia de newton
newton como ustedes sabrán es el padre
de la física moderna de la famosa ley de
la gravedad el que le terminó de dar
como las pinceladas finales a esta idea
de que el mundo entero es una máquina es
casi como un reloj
sin embargo y acá viene lo interesante
a mediados del siglo 20 se remata en la
casa sotheby's de londres un gran una
gran cantidad de cuadernos de notas
que estaban escritos en latín en
caracteres cifrados por puño y letra de
isaac newton los compras un economista
también muy famoso baina game peines los
hace descifrar y en 1942 exactamente 300
años después del nacimiento de newton en
una conferencia pública frente a la real
academia de ciencias de londres
qué nos dice newton no fue el primero de
la edad de la razón
newton fue el último de los grandes
magos esos manuscritos demostraban que
newton había sido un alquimista
la alquimia es una ciencia tradicional
que buscaba develar
las leyes ocultas en la naturaleza
que buscaba las condiciones de los
elementos y fundamentalmente transmutar
los metales convertir el plomo en oro
pero no era sólo una cuestión de
manipulación de la materia y de los
elementos
sino que ellos buscaban lo que llamaban
el elixir de la vida la piedra filosofal
que al mismo tiempo que se transmutará
en los metales en su laboratorio en el
alambique interior del alquimista
estuviera sucediendo una transformación
de sus instintos más básicos de su plomo
vital en aquello más sutil más luminoso
el oro de su espíritu
newton evidentemente estaba inspirado en
esta búsqueda de que consideraba que
toda la materia estaba animada por vida
por principios activos como él decía
sin embargo en su carrera como
científico
llegó un punto como podríamos decir una
encrucijada la famosa ley de la gravedad
la columna central de toda su teoría no
podía ser explicada en los términos del
paradigma que le estaba buscando imponer
es decir en los términos mecanicistas
de modo que no podía dar una respuesta
científica y tampoco podía dar una
respuesta hermética porque eso le
hubiera cerrado las puertas de la real
académia y también de la abadía de
westminster donde finalmente fue
enterrado con toda su pompa
de modo que newton tuvo un punto de
inflexión en su vida seguramente
y tuvo que elegir
entre ser fiel a sus principios
herméticos de alquimista o el camino del
éxito la gloria la fama de su ego
personal
finalmente elige este camino pero algo
seguramente quedó en el camino
si vemos la expresión de su rostro cómo
fue cambiando a lo largo de la vida nos
damos cuenta que desde esa mirada
soñadora del joven newton hasta esa
expresión adusta seria de ese señor
mayor con peluca casi amargados que fue
así retratado poco antes de su muerte
algo quedó en el camino lo que quedó en
el camino fue su propia piedra filosofal
optó por el camino del ego y no por el
camino de su ser más esencial
y vuelvo a una experiencia personal
nuevamente referida cuando yo estaba
escribiendo mi libro porque esta
historia no la cuento como una mera
curiosidad sino porque a mí
personalmente me llegó me emocionó mucho
tal vez porque me sentí identificada en
esto de que en algún momento renuncié a
algo muy importante y elegí otro camino
que me iba a dar como más prestigio
académico intelectual
y porque sentí que algo de esto de la
historia de newton que anticipaba un
dilema existencial muy propio de muchos
de nosotros quien no se ha visto en esta
disyuntiva entre lo que nos gusta y lo
que debemos entre la vocación la voz del
alma justamente y los mandatos
familiares quien no ha querido ser
artista y terminó siendo ese empleado
abogado por decir perdón por estas
profesiones pero hemos aprendido a
desconfiar a desconfiar de la magia a
desconfiar de las voces interiores a
desconfiar de la intuición a desconfiar
ya no escuchar las voces interiores
y no será la depresión la tristeza el
sinsentido estos males de época que nos
afligen de alguna u otra manera a todos
lo que está expresando
que socialmente hemos elegido el camino
de renunciar a la magia por eso hoy
quiero invitarlos
justamente
a poner en resonancia lo personal con lo
social que esto es una
experiencia muy transformadora ya no
renunciar a nuestra magia personal
tal vez newton no pudo hacerlo tal vez
no quiso tal vez hizo lo que debía hacer
para su época
y nos ha dejado un gran legado
no solamente en sus teorías científicas
su legado existencial de época que fue
mostrarnos que en ese momento para
triunfar había que renunciar
pero ahora estamos en otro momento ahora
estamos en otra época esta es la época
de no disociar de no renunciar es la
época de la coherencia entre lo interno
y lo externo es la época de buscar
la magia personal no solo de no
renunciar de buscarla de enaltecer la
como un componente esencial de la vida
como un principio activo creativo y
transformador y no solo como algo
personal para nuestro individualismo
hedonista sino porque cada vez que
hacemos resonar nuestra cuerda más
profunda y la hacemos sonar lo mejor
posible eso resuena con la cuerda de
todos los demás y esta es la manera y la
propuesta de volver a reencantar no sólo
nuestro propio mundo de volver a
reencantar el mundo para todos gracias
[Aplausos]
a veces
[Música]